bien la parole est à Jean-Claude Lenoir
pour le groupe UMP merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre pour
accéder au pouvoir François Hollande a
fait un cadeau très coûteux aux
écologistes il a indiqué qu'il allait
fermer la centrale nucléaire de
Fessenheim vous-même à peine Noémie
ministre vous avez fait une déclaration
authenticente dans le Journal du
Dimanche du 21 juillet je fermerai
festenheim avant la fin de 2016 alors
Monsieur ministre cette décision si elle
était menée à bien est absurde d'abord
parce que ça donne produit beaucoup
d'électricité 88% des besoins de
l'Alsace 3% de besoin de la France
d'autre part
m'apporte 400 à 500 millions d'euros de
recettes à EDF fait travailler 800
salariés directement et un peu plus de
1000 indirectement
j'ajoute que
pour mener à bien cette entreprise
monsieur le ministre il faut remplir un
certain nombre de conditions d'abord ce
n'est pas le gouvernement qui pilote
Fessenheim ce n'est pas le gouvernement
qui pilote une centrale nucléaire une
centrale nucléaire et pilotée par un
exploitant sous le contrôle de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire or
l'autorité à autorisé il y a peu de
temps EDF a poursuivre
l'exploitation de Fessenheim pendant 10
ans sous réserve d'un certain nombre de
travaux qui sont pour l'essentiel
terminé et seront complètement achevés
d'ici à la fin de décembre 2013 je
rappelle d'autre part que Fessenheim
n'est pas la seule propriété d'EDF aux
deux tiers l'entretière est partagée
entre EnBW Allemand et un consortium
Suisse alors la fermeture de Fessenheim
expose dangereusement la France d'abord
nous allons manquer d'électricité
deuxièmement nous allons devoir verser
nous allons devoir verser des
dédommagements à ceux qui sont avec EDF
propriétaire de la centrale
troisièmement vous contrevenez à ce qu'a
décidé l'autorité de nucléaire
quatrièmement rien aujourd'hui dans la
loi ne permet à un gouvernement de se
substituer à ceux qui gère une centrale
nucléaire merci pour les réponses lui
apporterait à ces questions importantes
très bien alors Monsieur Philippe Martin
pour répondre
le président de la République est le
premier minis sont fixés une méthode et
des objectifs la méthode c'est la
diversification de notre mix les
objectifs c'est une réduction de la part
du nucléaire à 50%, une réduction de
notre consommation finale d'énergie de
50 % l'horizon 2050 une réduction de 30
% de notre consommation d'énergie
fossile et 23% d'énergie d'origine
renouvelable en 2020 chez le sénateur
les décisions à venir sur la gestion du
parc nucléaire de la France devait être
compatibles avec cette méthode et ses
objectifs pour l'avenir pour l'ensemble
du parc nucléaire les décisions devront
être prises sous réserve bien sûr de la
vie de l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire
mais monsieur Lenoir c'est ce qui nous
différencie vous vous n'aimez pas que
l'État soit stratège vous laissez à EDF
et à une autorité de sûreté le soin de
dire les choses nous ce que nous voulons
c'est ramener l'État dans le rôle qui
doit être le sien il y a l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire qui peut effectivement
donner son avis pour des raisons sûreté
il y a EDF qui peut donner son avis pour
des raisons économiques et il y a l'état
qui doit effectivement donner et être le
garant de la stratégie énergétique et
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
Lenoir je vous confirme que dans la loi
de transition énergétique il y aura ce
retour de l'État stratège et que oui que
vous le vouliez ou non il y aura bien
une fermeture de Fessenheim à la fin
alors si le souhaite la réplique pour
Monsieur le douar c'est le mini je vous
donne rendez-vous fin 2016 vous l'aurez
pas fermé la centrale de Fessenheim vous
pouvez éventuellement l'arrêter en ne
nourrissant pas la centrale de
combustible mais je vous rappelle que
les règles qui s'appliquent au titre de
la sûreté nucléaire ne permettraient pas
à l'exploitant de conserver une Centrale
qui ne fonctionnerait pas au-delà de
deux ans il faut alors se soumettre à
des règles qui sont précises dans la loi
et qui confie à la SN non pas le squat
de donner des avis monsieur le ministre
mais de prendre des décisions dans cette
affaire puisqu'on parle de la politique
européenne de l'énergie je rappelle une
chose votre référence c'est l'Allemagne
qui est actuellement en train
d'augmenter la production d'électricité
à partir de charbon de lignes du charbon
qui vient des États-Unis actuellement le
problème du CO2 le problème des gaz à
effet de serre il n'est pas en France
grâce au nucléaire il est en Allemagne
alors Monsieur le Ministre mettez toute
la fougue dont je sais que vous êtes
capable pour convaincre les Allemands
d'arrêter la production d'électricité à
partir de charbon
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Roland Courtot pour le groupe socialiste
merci